good morning Hank it's Monday today I'm
going to talk about credit crunches why
they're so evil and how you and I and
all of nerdfighteria could dramatically
decrease worldsuck if we just became
better bankers I'm so bad at baking
let's say baking or banking I don't know
I'm bad at both okay so all the numbers
in this example are gonna be made up to
make the math easy for me because I'm
bad at math but say I have a fantastic
business idea like say I have a business
idea to make posters that say keep calm
and dftba it's important though that
this idea if it's a good idea isn't just
good for me like I don't want to brag or
anything but if my business idea is
successful then a number of people's
jobs will kind of partly depend on it
right there's the nerdfighter can make
the poster design but they're also the
people who make the poster paper the
people who print posters the people who
distribute and ship posters so that's
not just true with posters by the way
it's true of almost every good and
service in the economy so I got a great
idea but I have a problem which is that
I have a baby and I have to take all the
money that I make and turn it into food
which then he turns into poop
essentially all my money is getting
pooped out so how am I gonna get my
posters I'm gonna go to a place with
money specifically in Bank and I'm gonna
be like listen I want $100 so I could
print these posters they're gonna be a
big hit everybody's gonna love them then
the bank will take a hard look at me
appreciated my rugged good looks and
agree with me that people like to be
reminded to keep calm and not forget to
be awesome and they'll be like all right
here's otter bucks so I get my poster
printed I sell them say I have $200 then
I have to give $100 plus interest back
to the bank and then I've got to pay my
baby to poop and I gotta pay the rent
and buy a $24 I phone case and low and
behold I don't have another hundred
dollars to spend on posters so I go back
to the bank and I'm like hey it's me the
ruggedly handsome guy with the poster
idea I need another 100 bucks so I can
sell more posters in there like sorry
and I'm like what it's me do you not
remember the poster do I need to
unbutton a button for you and they're
like no sorry it's just there's a credit
crunch we're not really loaning money
right now why do banks do this because
in times of economic panic they have to
hold onto a much larger percentage of
their deposits in order to prevent like
bank runs so essentially we all sit on a
big pile of capital that we could be
investing in good ideas like my poster
company that would create jobs Hank I'm
pretty worried there's a credit crunch
coming but I am not as worried about you
or me or the posters as I am about the
hundreds of millions of people who have
emerged from poverty in the last 40
years because entrepreneurs in the
developing world depend much more than
we do on low-interest loans to buy the
things that they need to make the things
that they sell to buy spare parts for
taxis or
for agriculture or cosmetics if they
sell in local stores or food for
neighborhood restaurants which brings me
to kiva.org a website that allows you or
me or anyone to be a banker for
entrepreneurs in the developing world
you pick the entrepreneurs you want to
work with from around the world and then
you loan them money and there is a 98.5
percent chance that they pay you back
whereupon you can real own that money
forever or take it out at some point if
you want to thank admittedly you don't
make any interest on this deal but as
you may have noticed you also don't make
any interest in regular banking these
days anyway Hank I started wanting to
keep in 2007 I've had a 100% payback
rate but I logged on yesterday to find
that I had nine hundred and thirteen
dollars that I wasn't loaning to anyone
in short a guy had become that scared
banker who refuses to invest in good
ideas so I reload my money to a bunch of
entrepreneurs I also joined the Kiva
nerdfighters group link in the
doobly-doo which is pretty amazing like
if you scroll down there you'll see that
we've won more than 33 thousand dollars
but I think we can do even better so
Hank nerdfighters I encourage you to
check out the kiva.org nerdfighter group
you can join just by click and join you
can loan as little as $25 like I said
before they pay you back 98.5 percent of
the time but the most exciting thing is
that you get to be an awesome banker
there's a phrase you don't hear much
anymore you get to facilitate
sustainable economic growth in the
developing world so yeah hey bankers can
reduce world suck and we can be bankers
the truth resists simplicity don't
forget to be awesome I'll see you on
Wednesday
oh and PS those boosters not just a
rhetorical gambit they're actually for
sale so if you want a poster or if you
want to indirectly purchase some baby
poop head on over to dftba.com